je sais ce que j'ai à faire je me suis
fait embaucher comme willer comme
convenu
pouvez vous me dire si mal il se sert de
la boîte de nuit pour être les akan ce
mec est seul
il est dangereux
d'après ce que je peux voir il prépare
un gros coup à la marchandise ont
également pêchera de réaliser leurs
projets vous nous avez évolué notre pays
on est partis comme des chiens on
revient des lions
je suis en place ses hommes sont
dangereux dit pas
à la voiture piégée seront perpétrés par
nous sommes dans le centre d'alger
j'ai plus de couverture ils savent qui
je suis je veux tout savoir sur lui il
va falloir s'en occuper
je détiens au nom du renouveau de l' os
des diplomates étrangers
nous demandons la reconnaissance de nos
martyrs si nous n'obtenons pas
satisfaction ont pu mais c'est que si tu
trouves pour les otages [ __ ] s'est
saisi de mike tyson ne touche pas à mon
pote justin